apologize for having some fun i know you
always look great i'm all fuzzed up yeah
uh were you wearing like a coat over
there because there's white [ __ ] all
over you uh you know what this is the
truth you know what daddy did what can
the back of his car you can't have me in
a mirror because what i'd start doing is
i start trimming my beard and my hair oh
maybe oh it's probably great from your
beard yeah oh trim up a little bit i
trim up a little bit mm-hmm yeah there
you go yeah do a little trim trim yeah
ain't nothing with that now one of my
koi fish was missing oh yeah you know
what good
hey
hey hey
i freaked out uh-huh uh i i got really
mad and i was gonna set a trap for this
[ __ ] raccoon yeah he came back he
killed hilda he didn't though he would
have my koi has never been no my koi's
never been shy something happened last
night because my koi wouldn't come out
and when i feed them
they freak out and my one koi was hiding
in the bushes yeah
and uh he finally came out well he's
dead oh no no
he's in the water yeah i saw him because
the bushes cover the water part of the
water [ __ ] raccoon you [ __ ]
or something hey you know how you're
getting older how about
your pond i know
or the weather
or the weather that's my dad's go to
when we have anything to say this
how's that weather out there now are you
sunny you know you and i like i've
always appreciated the fact that
you and i have
very little tolerance for most talk
i like make me laugh yeah teach me
something give me some gossip yeah but
if i start if i were to say to you like
with brandon i've never done this
because i know yeah yeah but but i'll
give you an example i'll be like um
dude there was a uh mountain when we
were we were gonna fight
he's already out yeah
the other day he calls he goes dude
these nfts i went you're talking about
after yours yeah
i went nope click
how about when i was just i was like
he's talk click hold on there was that
we had a hung up on him there was a
thread was there anything new on him he
was literally in the middle of
conversations like dude these towed nfts
i went oh you called me talking at you
as yeah click
we sold over two thousand uh hold on
really yeah over two i was surprised i
was like oh [ __ ] we sold a lot of please
see
no fun toads i don't know well no more
free marketing i asked i asked but i
also said you know how many are
available we got to see what's going on
sell 20 000. yeah yeah but uh we sold a
shitload the people are buying them what
happens is it becomes this snowball
thing where people are like but it does
hey here's what's gonna happen yeah you
drop some money okay and that's fine
yeah and you're they're not gonna go for
whatever eight hundred thousand dollars
or whatever you think that's going to go
i know i don't know what's going to go
for it dude he didn't say 800 times he
said a hundred thousand that's not that
it's not
this is my new thing i can't stand
inspirational clips on on instagram i
can't stand when i see people who are
like dude you know the thing about
relationships at the end of the
relationships it's not just about love
it's not and it's like this clip and
there's music behind it so i sent
brandon there's some we know something
you sent brendan one yeah yeah and then
i sent him another thing okay we know
the things i'm saying
i sent him a video of me i just have a
picture of me in my underwear cause i
got a shark underwear of course
sharky's hungry
sharky needs a snack
snacking house and then i sent him a
video of like a little girl singing and
then i sent him another video of this
guy who's annoying he's clearly bored in
the hotel yeah and then brennan's kind
of like he gets he goes ah man i can't
believe that guy's still doing that
[ __ ] and i'm like yeah no right i
mean he's kidding what [ __ ] and i'm
trying to engage him in this
conversation you reply to all this i
don't ball in my hotel room several
tickets before i reply finally i just
get this i just get this hey you're
bored as [ __ ] keep sending me instagram
clips huh let's go ahead and stop it
okay
i was like gosh [ __ ] you stopped running
away the picture you and you're
baltimore i need you
i put no was that a nice area timonium
you know i mean listen
you know sometimes i've never seen the
wires okay so you know how there's a
warehouse that's emotion though yeah it
is you know the warehouse and then then
there's space and then there's another
yeah another warehouse space between the
warehouses space between timonium i
don't really think about it you know
yeah even the fir my first joke was i
was like hey i i uh googled things to do
in timonium and the first thing they
said the first thing it said was get the
[ __ ] out of someone
and they were like yeah you know yeah
that's right nothing going on at nine
o'clock at night it shuts the [ __ ] down
you couldn't even get us oh really no no
damn yeah i got to go there in april
yeah i feel like
i thought before that
no that's what i had to cancel because i
had got the uh the vid oh the videos the
videos look it's a good club magooby's
is they do sneak up people like i hear
yeah i heard it's good room
it'll sneak up no no yeah i'll be there
um no i'm headed here
do you see southwest uh regional
retracted i sure did we're just [ __ ]
around you're not be back today we're
just [ __ ] with you like is a over a
thousand flights were getting canceled
so many [ __ ] [ __ ] i think well one
of the other major airlines was like
yeah we're not doing that either yeah
they learned the hard way yeah well you
said every every airline was on board at
first with that they were leaning that
way and then once they saw the backlash
of southwest yeah they're like because
it's a business yeah like they're like
it's like a [ __ ] major hit yeah it's
a business i mean way to go guys like
what'd you think was gonna happen yeah
what the [ __ ] but i do think they're
gonna win this whole thing i think at
the end of the day they're already yeah
they're winning yeah yeah there's really
no way to unless you move to texas or
nashville i'm not women i'm not
anti-vaccine yeah but i'm not i'm
anti-vaxxed kids i'm an anti-venom
that's a different story because kids
don't i just haven't seen any evidence
but but it's not to protect kids to
protect the teachers the the adults we
know kids they don't suffer from yeah
the only problem with that is that
teachers get vaccinated and but here's
here's the problem with that teachers
and have an out so the teachers union
which is like the baseball union they're
so powerful teachers can get go hey i'm
either gonna get vaccinated or you can
test me every day yeah so they have they
have an option kids do not they do not
and they're trying to pass it with fda
to from you know five year olds to twice
that's gonna get so dicey and you get
diced so dicey right now though the one
thing i will say is that you need 10
vaccines to go to a public school so my
kids have to have their vaccine that
proof of vaccine i've heard this
argument here's the difference with that
those vaccines you're talking about
polio they're different all that [ __ ]
they're different but they've also been
they've also been research
for years and years and years yes how
long has this children's vaccination for
cove had been studied
about 10 minutes 10 minutes you can put
that in your kid you take that risk not
a [ __ ] chance yeah now in two years
or three years if it comes out
it goes through the regular protocols
i'm not anti-vaccine
i know you're not it's understandable
that parents like myself like you are a
little hesitant
because i think in many ways the
government hasn't communicated enough
they i don't trust i don't trust the
government i don't trust that
that the people in power have my best
interest in mind or my children's
destiny
i believe that ideology in a lot of ways
sort of their philosophy their their
idea their agenda their control over
what they want to push is a little bit
more important
i mean you have now gavin newsom who i
just was listening to rogan a guy who
tried to work with newsmonth most of the
people in power in california even
agree with this guy who was trying to
cure homelessness he wrote a book called
san francisco
he's like homelessness is yeah and and
he was like how do progressives ruin
america's cities part of it is just
basically saying well they're victims
and there should be no consequences for
their behavior so you're an addict that
doesn't work in in
the netherlands and portugal these po
these countries that have amazing drug
policies
it's not legal to shoot up but there are
consequences and there are carrots and
sticks what's the reward and you get
also consequences for being a fuck-up
you can't just have no consequences and
say well you're a victim and that was
kind of the argument but he was talking
about gavin newsom and the guy who was
at the charge of all the homeless
psychiatric policies yeah it's a it's a
leadership issue he said what do you
mean he goes and the guy goes i don't
think gavin is a bad guy he goes and
rogan said really and he goes no no i
don't think that he's just not doesn't
have the intellectual software
yeah right yeah
i don't know like
and he goes with that guy my software is
[ __ ] up
well he just doesn't read
and
he does it he goes not at all because i
don't want to be mean go wrong because
not being mean you just tell them the
truth yeah important job the guy doesn't
read yeah not at all so he's and i've uh
i have right i i have my reasons for for
believing that i i in california i've
had some exposure to him and i i know
people who know him yeah mm-hmm not
impressive that way not not not not a
big yeah yeah yeah looks the part but
not
and and tends to toe that [ __ ] line
so um forgive me if i don't trust
what he has to say no that's fair never
have yeah
wait what was this book
that you were talking about it's called
san francisco and rogan just had him on
his podcast
really really and this guy was a hard
left [ __ ] you know he worked with the
soros foundation and all that stuff and
he but but he's like look man
you you there are there are ways to
solve this problem and the way we're
doing it now is not how to solve the
problem it's not going to solve the
homeless yeah
we have probably actually a hundred and
fifty thousand right so the same friends
sicko uh progressive claimed that he
knew how to solve the homeless
problem inequality and crime but in
cities they control progressives made
those problems worse yeah he lived in
san fran uh for 30 years during that
time he advocated
uh the criminalization of drugs
alternative jail to prison so he's a
left-wing guy this is a left-wing guy
taking his own group to task for the
fact that they they just are and by the
way and so apparently george soros is to
blame partially because he funds the
most
far-left progressives i don't know what
it is but the [ __ ] um you know san
francisco city council l.a city council
they don't even really have democrats on
there these are socialists and far left
radicals far left radicals like i'm
talking about marxists and stuff so what
do they what do they want to be done
with well the idea would be the idea
would be
homelessness the long narrative was
homelessness was a housing shortage well
this guy's been studying it i mean in
the trenches for 20 years he goes i've
never seen that it's all drugs and it's
all mental illness it's schizophrenia
and it's drugs
when are we going to come to terms with
that and there are ways like other
countries have done really well at
dealing with it they just create that
like if you're caught doing drugs so in
holland if you're caught shooting up
well they'll take you to jail now what
happens is you show up and there's a
prosecutor there are police there's also
your family there's also a counselor a
caseworker and i assume when they go to
prison in those areas they're not
getting because you know your jail
prison is more there it's just more drug
dealing more yeah
yeah yeah here we house our crazies and
unfortunately a lot of people have
mental illness not their fault man you
have people on the street who have
schizophrenia yeah and you can keep a
one an old lady with dementia uh under
her house arrest essentially or you know
but the aclu the american civil
liberties union which i which i which i
support for the most part they they're
like you can't wear an ankle bracelet if
you're a drug addict that's that's a
violation there are civil liberties and
if somebody's a schizophrenic
you're not allowed to house them you're
not allowed to essentially take them off
the street because they're just the best
their best bet is just to leave them on
the street
yeah they're afraid that the state will
start running state-run hospitals it'll
be one flew over the cuckoo's nest but
again this is the americans have trouble
being good luck solving them yeah that's
a [ __ ] well he said so he said and
rogan and he were talking about
something really interesting they were
like the problem is that we're
politically homeless guys like you and
me we're all political i don't have a
team
i can't join with the republicans
because they're they're they're not
pro-choice they don't want to legalize
drugs they got a lot of issues you know
i i can't go with the progressives
because they want to decriminalize the
border and they're [ __ ] crazy
so where do i go if i'm if i'm socially
liberal fiscally conservative
unreasonable yeah and that rogers and we
need a new internet
so we should lock you up me yeah where
wherever you want to be nice
scared you've been down the skid row oh
sure oh my gosh well
it's called l.a now it's called venice
now west side not where i'm at i haven't
seen a homeless in hot seconds since i
don't go to the west side yeah it's it's
down skid row's downtown right yeah
that's where uh the nightstalker used to
hang out because he could get away with
[ __ ] there yeah he just you know jumping
in a picture of it everyone looks crazy
you should actually go no
i wouldn't advise it no i wouldn't worry
we i guess we both live there around
there it's something that you should see
to realize what's actually happening
here you know right next to little tokyo
like like not every state has a [ __ ]
skid row no skid row is like its own
freaking town of just like zombie
homelessness yeah because i was confused
[Music]
that's a moccasin that's terrible that's
what uh sarah silverman has just talked
about how his feet turn to moccasins but
there's like it's in shape i know right
there's some noise yeah he was talking
about how the drug dealers down there
are like that and they enforce the law
oh yeah it's like that so they they run
the there's they have uh those are bad
places to be oh you don't want to go
down there yeah why would i want to do
it you don't need to see it
yeah
see there's people that look sort of
normal but yeah well drugs well remember
they thought cover is going to take over
the homeless but the homeless like have
antibodies do it yeah
we're dealing with the black plague man
hey dude
sometimes you don't want to get in the
car no way you have to drive i need my
snackies man you need your snackies but
i want them delivered to me i don't know
spend too much dude i'm watching the
crown or you're watching freaking squid
game sure yeah whatever you're watching
i just want to cozy up under a blankie
plant because it's getting to be full by
snackies i need grubhub man grubhub they
got you covered man grubhub works hard
to serve restaurants so they can work
hard to serve you
all right and please scroll down chin
hell yeah dude today grubhub's doing a
little extra to serve panera get free
delivery perk on your first order from
panera 15 or more order through the
grubhub app or online grubhub we serve
restaurants and by the way panera was
rated as some of the best quality meat
you can get in all these different fast
food you know convenient food markets so
sure it is fantastic grubhub we serve
restaurants
you know a few decades ago private
citizens used to be largely that private
well dude think i'm not saying we do but
say you're s
scorching the internet for some weird
stuff
maybe you're looking at some porno
whatever you don't want people to know
what you're looking at you're into weird
kids people people can access everything
you browse yeah i watched your tweet yes
yeah yes listen when i want to keep my
data private when i go online i turn to
expressvpn
all right did you know there's hundreds
of data brokers out there who sold
business to buy and sell your data buy
it worst part is they don't have to tell
you who they're selling to or get your
consent i'm not about that man but with
expressvpn my connection gets rerouted
through an encrypted server and my ip
address is mass you don't know what i'm
looking at you know where i'm looking
from right right it's called privacy
yeah privacy which is dead it is a long
dead commodity and expressvpn is
bringing it back yep and the best part
is how easy expressvpn is to use no
matter what device you're on your phone
your laptop smart tv all you have to do
is tap one little button you get
protected so if you're like me and the
kid here you believe that your data is
your business all right um you need to
use expressvpn all right go to
expressvpn.com
fighter and get an extra three months
for free that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p
and dot-com fighter go to expressvpn.com
fighter to learn more uh but anyways uh
tenderloin is just it's not skid row i
mean it's hoodie but it's hoodie it's
just it's but it's a nerd
it's not skid row it's bad it's bad but
there's housing like skid row
san francisco is like you can do your
drugs right here people are shooting up
right in the street yeah they don't care
we saw that but there's actual housing
like compartments we saw people there
it's unbelievable tenderloin it's unreal
it's such a shame because it used to be
so nice well they ruined the city they
ruined san francisco it's weird they
just stick with it too yeah what can you
do yeah it's like schizophrenia is
taking dumps in the street there's a lot
of humans
oh
so yeah yeah
so that's kind of i see that
so they're they're victims and there are
no consequences you see what's going on
with kyrie irving
what happened so he basically they're
just going to trade him or he's just
going to sit out the season because he
refused to get vaccinated wow
puts his money where his mouth is i
guess right yeah and then the washington
state coach got fired the football coach
yeah she's give accidents so they fired
him howard stern could there be a bigger
soyboy than howard stern is he the king
of soyboys
yeah
i mean for kyrie it's a little uh
different
but
it's a tough it's tough right yeah it is
tough it's [ __ ] tough yeah
i mean i'm i believe i don't think he
likes basketball enough because if you
ask jordan or kobe to get vaccinated
even if you told them the like the side
effects they'd be like and i can't play
basketball i will stick that needle in
my the tube of my dick that's right you
know what i'm saying yeah ricardo's like
no i'm not doing that sometimes though
it's like just a stance and you can't
make me do this kind of stuff he has
enough money now where he does it really
it doesn't really matter but yeah i mean
personally i'm i believe in science and
vaccines and i don't think that this
vaccine after we've given it to billions
of people yeah yeah i just don't i don't
think that it has
it's a weird hill like because we don't
have to deal with it really it's a weird
hill to die on it's a weird hill but if
you were i have friends who where their
work literally emailed was like if you
don't give back there you're fired yeah
so it puts people on their on their back
you're like jesus christ it is a bit
aggressive if you're taking away your
livelihood yeah i don't it's a tough
hill to die on yeah but i also
understand that if you're super you do
and i know there's that difference with
this is an mdna or whatever rda
it's a different vaccine it's a
different kind of vaccine that yeah
but we are vaccines are mandated 10 of
them are men and my kids had to have 10
before they could go to school so every
kid does right yeah and i and i support
it i don't want i think that measles
mumps tetanus all these things are very
dangerous yeah and polio so i i'm i'm i
am support i am very much in support of
vaccines i understand to your point
it's new so people are like you know a
little hesitant yeah yeah
some people it's nice it's time
but the time my bigger issue is masks my
bigger excuse mask i'm [ __ ] sanjay
gupta like with rogue and it's like
do they actually do anything
oh yeah yeah i heard that vocalize all
right you got my kids using them
[ __ ] yeah i don't like that my
kids have to interact with each other
they can't see us on his face [ __ ] you i
have a huge problem with that so i'm i'm
very anti-mass for children yes but yeah
and you said that what washington state
football coach couldn't quit he just and
four other coaches quit they were just
like all right yeah it's a weird time
because
washington's super woke yeah so for him
he couldn't be in a worse state too it
is interesting
personality types some people are just
super
safe
and
it other people are
independent and
like it shows you if you get in a bind
like you know foxhole you're not going
to call some people
this is correct you haven't left your
house in two years and you were seven
masks in your car by yourself yeah what
do you can do when there's some real
[ __ ] popping they're gonna they're
you're gonna die
i'm gonna take their [ __ ] if zombies
really come where are we gonna do dude
i'm gonna have to take your stuff bro
yeah i'm gonna communicate and take all
your stuff you're in the way yeah we
gotta hang the outside just as as bait
yep
yeah and that's what happens yeah like i
wonder if the employees at thick boy if
i forced everyone to get back saying how
everyone feel you know it'd be a weird
stance it is
it's a that's it's an uncomfortable
difficult time yeah and i actually don't
know i find myself saying i don't know a
lot
but if you look at the bottom line you
look at like southwest who tried that
and they're like oh not everyone's like
us okay we're pulling back yeah so i do
the same [ __ ] if i force everyone in
here like you guys and all the other
employees so you have to be vected in
half you're like all right i quit i'm
like well hold on
hold on i need you hold on hold on here
huh yeah it's really weird it's really
weird
i don't know we do know that if you did
have covid your immunity is actually
much stronger
much stronger and they don't acknowledge
that that's what's weird it's much
stronger than with the vacuum we also
know that if you have covet and you take
the vaccine you have a much higher
chance of having a very strong reaction
yep
so wait a strong reaction to
all everybody in this room all of us
have had covered who else is that
coveted
i think everybody i know everyone right
yeah everyone but kyle
kyle wasn't with us when you got it yeah
i had it
did she have it she had the same she had
she's asymptomatic though she didn't
know until no i had symptoms but i
thought i was on my period you guys were
dying
me and brian me and brown were bad yeah
for a while you were dying and being
brian with colleen every year almost
every day brian call me everybody how
are you doing how are you doing yeah
steve you almost died steve you almost
died stevie had some trouble we talked
about yeah he had cancer so yeah is his
immune system
very very comfortable yeah yeah
yeah what can you do yeah you were okay
okay you were working unfortunately yeah
you got you were sick for a little bit
but you were fine yeah one day sir
i had the shakes like shakes i was like
shaking for a day and then i was ready
you didn't get a call for anything right
no nothing i just had a headache
and your loss of taste right yeah and
you were riding bikes every day yeah
my lungs are better which is weird yeah
yeah
i don't know we can and then you can
people are like this podcast with
michael rapport he was yelling at us the
entire time oh he was
you [ __ ] guys
we couldn't even
it was just a
he moved to new york i know yeah i love
him i talk to him yeah he's great yeah
the best so [ __ ] great he texts me
because he's coming into la soon he
wants to come on the show yeah let's get
him on yeah he's so funny he's put
coming to l.a you're going to suck me
all right dude yeah i'll get this i get
random text it'll be like let me see it
i'm like dude come on man
i'm a straight man he goes come on yeah
[Music]
alrighty hold on yeah what what we got
fight companion not this week next
saturday next saturday i'm excited about
that that's gonna be a fun one yeah we
gotta
do we bet two thousand dollars on peter
young of course yes you did two thousand
or thousands two thousand i remember two
thousand two and that's nice because i
have a bet on the y'all had a bet on the
wilder fury something there too oh no no
no it was the
canelo uh
yeah he's got he's got to go the
distance
uh oh
but but is this is this is the 30th also
covington
is just changing the date no oh it's not
no i think that's yeah november 6th
it said 30th and then it's the 29th it's
weird
what is it let's go to ufc you'll see
268 right 267 i think let's see
well this 266 is stacked one
cost 10
yeah i'll talk october 30th 627 guys at
it
oh oh
yawning to shara yep to sure actually
has a chance to win the title which is
crazy how amazing would that be his age
i know it's beautiful [ __ ] amazing
how does he be huh clover it has to be
44 at least yeah [ __ ]
find out
um look at that dan you got dan hooker
over maka jeff huh
uh i think he's been a tough night in
the office for mike jeff is that right
yeah just just strong
uh he's just he's a batman
i don't know 41.
so we're going to find out 41 41 we'll
find out 41 years thumbs
such a great fight it's ching i don't
know much about uh jingling he's just
he's the biggest head in the world
he's a crazy fighter he just goes crazy
oh really it's a great fight he one time
actually try to gouge someone's eyes out
which sucks what yeah
now he he's chinese right chinese
chinese
yeah um well he's dealing with kamza
who's a [ __ ]
mama
hasn't uh
well he hasn't fought in a while since
he had kobe
i feel bad for this girl verna because
everyone makes fun of because she has
her eyes are a little bit out
and they compare it to rob schneider a
lot as well oh she looks like schneider
that's what people say [ __ ] you guys
yeah yeah people are [ __ ]
yeah but anyways the main cards like
that's a lot by the way there's a lot of
daghestani names
yeah
go back down
[Applause]
it's
leroy
i bet he does to fight uh peter young
yeah i bet he does oh after yeah he'd
have to get past dude look you got it
tiger hold on back that's a nightmare
for john anderson they're all daryl
they're all [ __ ] russian you know
slash dagestani it's tough it's nice
your song is
yeah or he could be from mongolia or
something that's why i said most likely
chinese oh okay
that guy has a russian tattoo on his
[ __ ] ribs yes he doesn't see a hammer
and he's from united states
is a common name for dudes in russia
what is
andre
is it uh andre alaski is from belarus
you knew him pretty well right oh yeah
macho for a long time the the most much
yeah you told me that right yeah this is
a monster
oh man okay
damn did you train with him did you spar
with onstage oh you did that's why he's
weird that's right
yeah that's why it was a bad fight
once usually once two trading partners
when you know each other well it's like
yeah the most nerve-wracking it is right
you know each other's tendencies and all
that or yeah
so you kind of like each other it's
weird yeah that's weird i love that guy
he's the best still doing it he just won
last weekend jesus still can't get him
out of there still doing it still doing
it greatest quote of all time mma how
taste my pee pee
sylvia and him had the same girlfriend
that might
do you remember how hairy he was when he
first walked in he had heroin you ever
see him for when he first when you see
him when he first walked in he was 240
pounds when his championship fights
against him oh this is him right here
he had hair on his shoulders and
everything he did yeah yeah shoulders
even when i fought him hey
yeah
big boy
oh yeah he lives in chicago does he yeah
he was how long do you do this for
as long as he can holy [ __ ] that guy's
here this one was the hairiest guy in
efc he was a german yeah
that's he was the hairiest you got to
love that yeah
it doesn't look bad on him somehow he's
[ __ ] tough man i bet
well he's he's gorilla
look at him oh that's andre
andre he's such a beast still is still
doing the goddamn thing still doing it
that's back in the day
dude he's been fighting forever people's
bodies looked different back in the day
too
yeah
a lot erlosky has always looked good
though man yeah he has he's always been
a yeah just a real tough customer
freak
amazing all right jim what do you got
meanwhile brock lesnar had a hair on his
body
not a hair on his body as close to a
silver that's a blonde silverback blonde
silverback gorilla the longest [ __ ]
arms
just insane man and by the way looked
that way in high school
uh college dress oh yeah yeah oh dude
monster and teenagers of minnesota you
were swimming inside just it just
the ex you know the teeth popped up
yeah i mean even as a young kid look at
him oh my god he was
that's him in college i mean oh okay
i mean enjoy that enjoy that stuff back
then yeah look at
the one there the green look how long
his arms are and he's probably 12.
that's a high school dude
high school come get something
i mean
look at him 16 there when he was 16 16.
is that it or no no he's a freak bro
he's a different one he's 16 years old
he's a pet raccoon 13 39. he's a
pepperoni even at 13 he's jack yeah he's
jacked he's just he's just a genetic
friend
super freaked yeah super freak super
good guy too
so it popped up uh in the search his
teeth you guys remember his teeth right
what's wrong with them back in the day
no it's like the craziest teeth you've
ever seen really yeah you'll see right
here
that's his teeth he cried
that's why i've seen that before that's
when you grind it is insane
oh yeah that's from grinding from from
uh
oh
yeah
all righty oh god
yeah that's that's enough
here we go
baby sometimes i get oily skin dude or
we're always on the road new cities i'm
in florida your skin takes a bit of skin
gets clammy your skin gets clammy looks
like you're on the front
all the time it gets really dry so what
do you do dude i get disco disco's a
clean
skincare brand based in austin texas
that's right
yeah bro disco products are created
specifically for the bros oh from male
skinny dude how about this they got
issues for under eye bags check i get
some nuts under my eyes dark circles
acne shoulder burn
skin dry skin
wrinkles what
rings how are you not using this yeah i
got to get them all over your face i got
you got to take the guesswork out dude
disco products are easy to use all right
they're affordable all right uh if
you're looking to start skin care
routine for the first time disco starter
set is a no brainer the starter set is
all you got it's three simple set set
steps for just 60 seconds a day we're
talking about a face cleanser all right
they got a face scrub a hydrating face
moisturizer which i highly recommend all
right it's tsa approved bring on the
plane man if you want to check out disco
and try the incredible skincare products
for yourself we got a gift for you guys
man all right the fire kit audience
listeners and viewers go to
letsdisco.com
that's
www.letsdisco.com fighter or enter
fighter at checkout for 30 off your
first order that's disco.com fighter for
30 off your first order thank you disco
thank you disco
let's get checked let's get checked
let's get checked let's get checked
let's get checking you want to get your
chairs checked they go low dude how
about chin
chin's low jim's a soy boy now he's not
getting checked wow sorry chin look i've
had very high testosterone levels but
i'm getting older dude you don't know
you don't need to get checked out dude
lack of sleep dude stress hey bro diet
bros are you experiencing low energy
fatigue maybe your peace isn't working
all right maybe you don't have that sex
drive anxiety up the wazoo rainfall
brain fog enlarged breasts bloating
headaches yeah what all this all those
could be indicators of low testosterone
dude and that's why i'm excited to share
with you today let's get checked let's
get chad reward let's get checked at
home testing man here's how it works
simply go to their site all right order
the mail hormone advanced testing kit it
arrives at my door small little package
nobody needs to know you're worried
about this from there do a small finger
prick send the sample back to their lab
with the prepaid shipping label in two
to five days you get your results
completely online man we got you covered
man let's get checks mail home sorry a
nurse will contact you over for
consultation over the phone yeah man so
let's check out your test levels all
right let's check them out all right
their labs are clia approved cap
accredited with the highest levels of uh
accreditation you got this one it's fast
affordable convenient and totally
confidential use code fighter for 30 off
your entire order at t r y l g c dot com
fighter that's code fighter for 30 off
your entire order at t r y l g c dot com
slash fighter
on it
on it still the best supplements oh my
god still the number one supplements
you're the best been taken all right
around i'm never gonna turn it over
let's
i do oh but by the way still using
shroom tech it doesn't use who uses
other supplements other than spirulina i
don't trust anybody else vitamin d3
spray dude use other supplements do you
also watch your local new
don't wait till january first get your
thick ass in shape dude we got uh
protein powders we got coffee we got
fitness gear for your thick ass we got
kettlebells streaming workout fitness
programs at home you can have your
battle ropes jim you're on sandbags home
gym dude quad mace
we got it all dude on it.com slash
fighter temps
fighter temps off the best supplements
and fitness gear on the planet on it.com
so a teacher in south carolina was
recently fired and she's facing charges
because she has a prize box in her
classroom she's an elementary school
teacher there was a student that was
gonna grab something from the prize box
when she realized the student actually
grabbed an edible that she left in there
it was a brownie she says oh choose
something else was it a brownie or was
it the sour patch kids it was a brownie
and then the student put it back reached
in for something else and grabbed like
gummy uh like cbd gummies instead and
she didn't notice that time so later on
in the day the student asks somebody to
help open up the gummy so they can have
a treat the adult who is going to try to
open it for them notice that it says thc
level and it was super high so there was
an investigation that underwent seeing
where the child got the cbd government
high as [ __ ] no no no students ever
ended up eating it and you said i've
seen the bag though i get it why this
kid thought it was regular char yeah
when you see the bags
the issue is why are there cbd
products in a prize box that you're
supposed to be giving yeah
yeah that's what i don't give away so
she's facing charges my friend uh that's
her had a party a woman yes like eight
months pregnant
was had the munchies and ate all his uh
fruit loops and they were a plastic bag
fruit just animal and they were all
[ __ ]
weed there's wheat fruit yeah yeah wheat
everywhere
[ __ ] regular fruit meanwhile i'm not
super hot
yeah go to the hospital the doctor you
know the doctor said he goes not worried
about it yeah he goes yeah
it's it's alcohol i'd be worried about
not weed your baby will be fine
even with alcohol back in england and
they and even in america back in the day
like
80s
you're allowed to have about one glass
where it's not dangerous to the child
it's they don't yeah they don't
recommend anything else because people
will overdo it well now it's weird when
the girl's pregnant they tell you not to
eat this not to do this not to do that
yeah like no delicious coffee
i drank smoke
in the house my mother be like
absolutely like she doesn't give up
she's gonna give a [ __ ] yourself
especially in england they didn't give a
[ __ ] not a [ __ ]
now they're so like soft
soft
soft
it's like i so so
i know these people that are renting a
friend of mine's house and my other
friend is a plumber and his guys
you really do you love friends
he has a lot hey
do my run
because i'm sick of it because so many
stories like my friends
i have a friend because it's not true i
don't have time to tell you so please
don't actually yeah you know
actually the plug
just say this guy though
you know what i'm saying like
mike the guy does my laundry nobody does
that you might question oh do you know
this guy no but if he just says my
plumber it's like that makes me it's my
shortcut for like i don't want to say
you quit saying friends the connection
yeah but
my neighbor my old neighbor yeah yeah
not your friend and they were renting
this house and the plumbers that he
employs are smoking outside they're
plumbers
and they freaked out because the guy's
smoking on the sidewalk and somehow it's
wafting into their house get the [ __ ]
out of here can you talk to your friends
yeah my friends
wait speaking of friends real quick you
guys have connections to scopa right oh
yeah why
so what my girl made reservations for
friday night so if you want me to talk
and get that vip experience that'd be
amazing oh you just want oh but you got
a reservation we got a resume we just
want to be you know i want to just treat
her well so
well i'm not going to get you a free
meal no not free i don't want free no
just be like you know
i don't know friendly or something make
sure you get a good you just want to get
in there's no bad seats in the house and
there's no bad food yeah i mean if i you
know you could
all right never mind maybe maybe we'll
give you some [ __ ] squash blossoms on
the house or something yeah all right
cool but we can take you there sometime
that'd be awesome too yeah
last time he's like you want to do a
whiskey tasting we'll do a whiskey taste
that sounds awesome i'm the best whiskey
of all time
i'm not the connoisseur but you guys are
going friday chin friday night
that'd be nice i'll be in the minutes me
and cat are headed to uh i know four
nights yeah horror nights
friday night no universal uh oh
universal universal horror night yeah
universal horses cat stevie
joe obviously and then the english
couple yeah yep english
we don't know i don't know what the
counts are but let me tell you it's uh
the funny bone in liberty township not
cincinnati but outside cincinnati
brennan so let's go ahead and get there
our tickets at the funny bone
another great time yeah oh yeah
i'm looking forward to that
hey you know we did it friday saturday
on uh the new think boy vlog we hired a
new vlog guy like whole marketing
director guy and what he did on the vlog
is while the fans stay in line they have
christian with a thick boy mike go and
ask questions so they did [ __ ] mary kill
and it was you me and chappelle or you
me and chin and most people would marry
you
or marry me these guys were gold diggers
they're like i'd make a shot for his
money
every single one of them would kill
right off the bat kill chin well i don't
get it
i mean that's what you're saying too the
best of the guy goes you got stories man
i understand i kill him off the bat i
can't handle those stories
and another guy goes without dude so
christian goes [ __ ] marry kill uh
channing who's kill chan before you
hey you guys i just i'm not into of all
people because i just don't like asians
man that's so terrible i tried to hook
chin up because he just kept getting
like kill chin kill chance was like all
right i need to like get like a [ __ ]
chain or a marry chin or something so i
gave him nick stevie and chin and
immediately they didn't want to kill
chin because they don't know chin as
well so when you don't know somebody as
well no
you haven't seen the vlog so they do
david who they also don't know as well
and they're like i guess i would [ __ ]
date or another god [ __ ] brendan marry
david and kill chad
it was hilarious well jen's stories are
good but he they tend to end yeah well
the guy was saying
they're
the guy was saying they're two like we
don't know what he's doing yeah
usually i'd kill him because the stories
we don't know where he's at
that's what he said too general we don't
know what's going on
it's it's when the cops are asking you
something you robbed a bank and you're
like i i've been i was in the
this new creative director ahead this
kid is a [ __ ] beast really my god man
because i met with him first you know
how when you meet with people you never
[ __ ] know this guy got recommended
from another guy he comes in with a
[ __ ]
pad of paper 50 ideas wow like holy [ __ ]
dude you know you're not hired yet right
no i know i just want to show you what
what i'm thinking holy [ __ ]
ideas for what like just all fake boy
related stuff everything the channel
every the vlog
monster he was actually the guy who
helped us uh set up the date for chin on
cats oh really yeah he was the guy at
korean bbq with nick and i oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] yeah so he's been helping out for a
while he shot his own feature film like
own funding everything he's a beast
super beast
that's awesome yeah good good everything
came out really well too really well
filmed yeah he's good
we had a killer team
what could he do for uh absolutely
nothing
township
this weekend thursday through now friday
saturday friday saturday go see brian
friday saturday
yeah
go see brian
okay
so there was a plane crash where 21.
21 people boarded a private jet
from houston on their way to boston for
a baseball game very rich as [ __ ] yeah
rich as [ __ ] the plane actually crashes
and all 21 people miraculously yeah and
you see the head like holy [ __ ] they
survived plane crash nope never took off
the ground just was going straight and
it was like
and like it was still on the ground
seriously yes so oh so it never went the
air so it's not a plane crash no it's
nothing it's a
a fire happened everybody got off in the
plane yes okay but when you read it like
holy [ __ ]
thank god they survived yeah
it never left the air yeah that's not
survivable right there but burn brendan
you mentioned before like usually
airplane crashes happen when you take
off
yeah usually
correct unless someone hijacks plane
runs in a building
well there is that one there is that one
you can see in the video
they're filming this plane that just the
guy was right the guy he wrote his son a
letter you know they and they some of
them survived they were found them in
trees and stuff oh [ __ ] is that true it
crashed in there it just had technical
difficulty and they knew what they were
going down
well there's the exceptions the japanese
i think it was japanese airlines it's
[ __ ] amazing leonard skinner had a
crazy one too
yeah they all died though right yeah no
not all of them a lot of them
reba mcintyre i've done her show reba
and
before that it was probably like four
years oh the tv show yeah her whole band
was killed she was like crazy she ran
into a mountain her whole band that
she'd been touring for with forever yeah
she's a great person too she was very
clever i've seen her live you know
harrison ford flies down planes right he
crashed
he came out of santa monica airport kid
flies home he's probably you know he's
always high 24 7. yeah and he went up
and then had to land and crash landed in
a golf course he got out on skate yeah
[ __ ] didn't give a [ __ ] yeah just walked
away
lead singer of offspring also i'm
curious how many private planes and jets
crash because that seems to be the only
ones crashed you never hear like the
major airlines crashing ever it's only
private jets yeah my dad crashed
and his buddy broke his foot and that
was it what
yeah my dad was an amateur pilot he used
to fly float so he was flying the train
oh he was flying the plane yep
holy crap
that'd be scary we had the propellers of
the plane in our front yard bent like
this wow you crashed into the house
no
actually i know my dad
hey
you remember my grandpa in world war ii
the nazi story
now it's a fun story for the shop there
hold on yeah but then when i read my
history i'm like brandon
did that happen brendan i like how i
like the questions but if i may yeah
there's him playing with with his buddy
dick joyce
hey you think there's turbulence no hold
on no they lost electrical power
my dad
crashed in your front yard land in that
field my dad said too close to houses
we're going to try to land the
connecticut river it's going to be very
cold yeah because you want to go into
the water yeah and then they saw a
landing strip
it was an abandoned one and they landed
on the landing strip they landed on the
landing strip also didn't crash hold on
without
without it was a crash landing oh yeah
but you glide into it yeah yeah
but you know
plan was total scary scary no matter
what yeah
we did mess up the propellers and we had
to throw the plane away yeah mm-hmm
but daddy bought a new one daddy bought
a new one
yeah that's not a crash landing
so remember when i was saying the nazi
story out loud sure as i'm saying i was
like i know the chance of that happening
is not good that happens it also sounds
like a movie a little bit
my dad sticks by it yeah
reality versus what really happens
happens all the time got in a fight in a
box called tell us what happens it's
telling this game of telephone as it
gets passed i can't imagine i i blocked
him boom never happened
oh by the way
when we were in the car with your dad
going to the game he does say uh terry
uh you
i did that for you guys yeah he's
straight up at the broncos and i was
like dad that quarterback's not bad and
i looked at back at the guys he's like
yeah you know with terry i'm like he's
teddy he's straight up
yeah that's that's you guys have that
alpha thing going on locking horns
locking horns i guess but your dad your
dad won't suffer fools if somebody's got
a point of view about a political
he'll be like what what do you not like
about stuff it's like oh stuff
what else got you
ready
so kanye west is walking around new york
city with this weird white mask oh he
went white face
yeah
now if a white guy did yes like let's
say leonardo dicaprio was saw with a
black mask i don't know that's a good
question oh dude all the backlash give
me backlash no question yeah so connie
is just wearing this white man
yeah maybe he's trying to hide his
terrible haircut who knows did he cut it
himself
i no i believe he had a barber cut it i
don't know what he asked for but it
looks horrendous does he not know that
people are going to be looking at him
that's a very strange way to behave that
brings more attention god does and now
that we know that's kanye dude you're
the easiest guy to spot now
he got into a cab like this
might be nice from the guys like all
right dude i guess
that terrifies me and i'd be like you're
not getting my cat because you're going
to oh you ever seen that this skit that
skits so this sketch is so funny i never
saw it well eddie murphy yeah i never
saw honey
joe's as a white white male for a day
it's so funny
netflix the owner of netflix uh
he he did some uh
press thing or something with asking a
question about dave chappelle because
you know the trans and uh
uh lgbqt community like did a walk
lgbtq because questioning there's
another classes you know 2s stands for
two-spirit okay but you know what i'm
talking about right sure so we're good
so um they did they they staged that
walk out and then he did questions at
that thing
and they're asking like are you gonna
pull it down and he goes you know we've
made a lot of mistakes with handlings
internally he goes but as far as we give
the artist the freedom of creativity
which a lot of people appreciate they're
like well where do you draw the line
these people say he's like i draw the
line at if they're
putting out harm like specifically
saying things that will harm people yeah
that's why i've drawn the line i don't
think david did that yeah and then he
was saying also
that um
they're like well do you have any
you know is there any timeline whether
you're gonna pull the dave chappelle's
rush down he goes no he goes not at all
and he goes we actually haven't had that
many people asked for it to be taken
down yeah yeah had about four yeah
it's a very poor very loud it's very
four very loud fanatics called fanatics
don't let fanatics do that to you oh
speaking of netflix uh theo von dropped
a special
yep it's available now on netflix go see
it there you go if you don't like it you
ain't [ __ ]
what are you guys talking about normal
people i think regular people regular
people people
all right so my picture-in-picture has
been compromised
on [ __ ] quizno subs when he says
everyone's about 11 percent gay he was
like have you ever been to i don't want
to do the joke but it's
so [ __ ] funny it's great it talks
about two two dudes locking eyes while
you're in a quizno's hot sub with all
the meat in it
dude i watched it at 6am with my kiddos
i woke my kid up laughing so hard that's
so great
mm-hmm he's so unique he's so unique
he's such a unique
crushes it man okay by the quickness too
they even see the new halloween movie no
i saw the i said bro you're jamie
covered you know you know what you know
it crushed you know what crushed uh
sorry your face is gonna be covered
because my picture picture's messed up
right now but yeah uh i saw them you
know what beat out uh double 07 the box
office crushed it yeah close crushed
holy [ __ ] crushed it because and i was
telling my buddy who's involved heavily
probably the most influential guy in the
movie system was talking to him about it
he was what they're finding out with
these because i go is the movie business
bouncing back he was well what's
interesting he's like sure same thing
comedy which is true
he goes there's certain comics who can
still sell well during the pandemic and
like cove it like if you have a bro
audience which i do he's like they're
they're going to take the risk and buy a
tick and go watch you perform because
but if you're an older comic the older
fans they're not coming out they're
afraid they're afraid
you know to each their own that's fine
but with the movies right double07
probably an older audience sure they
didn't come out and buy it halloween
scary movie young audience people
crushed it wow so the the the movie
industry is trying to figure it out like
production is fully back yeah but as far
as like them trying to figure out you
know like james bond tanked basically
when normally it's a shoe-in for them or
chewing but but they're they gotta
figure out like what audience are still
gonna come out and see it you know
that was also like wasn't that daniel
craig and then there was a black woman
who was the new
double seven
there's a black lady who plays double07
and they made um
q i think his name is gay in the new one
that just came out well it could be a
problem too for them why'd they make you
gay no why can't you just do his job
yeah they couldn't just listen you have
to suck people off and do his job
a lot of uh
like what the [ __ ] yeah like what do you
yeah that's important like that that's
why is q have to be why do we have to
care about huge sexuality like the whole
point is that you didn't know what their
sexual they were yeah you they just did
the [ __ ] thing yeah trying to save a
world a lot of a lot of the people were
saying that they wouldn't have had a
problem with it if they introduced a new
character as gay or an interesting
instead of making this instead of
completely rewriting
and they said that if there was another
like if the if the person who played
double seven like the black lady came in
and was a different agent then that
would have been fine and if she took
over the franchise that'd be fine but
there's only one double 07. yeah so dude
right i'm balls deep in the crown right
i can't get enough let's start doing all
my research on english history and the
britain empire can't get enough of it
balls deep which is weird because when i
was in high school in college you
couldn't give a flying now it's so
interesting right
dude
try this so the crown
there it's four seasons the first two
it's queen elizabeth the second you have
to call her that queen elizabeth ii
in her younger years then when they go
to season three and four she's older
she's like mid 50s
instead of using the same the entire
cast instead of just using makeup and
renderings and making them older they
just
casted a whole new cast so you say
you're watching a show let's say you're
watching a show and your balls deep in
it and let's say you're watching
stranger things so they're getting older
and they just flip the cast because they
get older and it's brand new people yeah
we have no connection to them
drives me [ __ ] not so because i love
the original but it's still good though
it's so good it's so well done yeah it's
[ __ ] yeah it's so well done it's
great i think they both won uh
academy awards yeah but still
because you started the scene and i was
like who the [ __ ] that you don't know
like who the [ __ ] is that yeah my girl's
like that's queen elizabeth since when
and then the husband who's great on it
you find out all the [ __ ] about uh
prince phillips it's nuts dude yeah it's
nuts
weird really weird it's how weird is
that yeah and they're just all cool with
it why would they do that just because
they were older and they figured well i
get and so i looked up because i had to
outrage about it and i'll see i'm a
little late because it's been out for a
while but i went online people are upset
but the the net the director came out
was like this was always the plan like
we told her what we're doing like uh the
original actress and actors when they
signed the contract was just they knew
it was just for two seasons every two
seasons we switch out the entire task
which i don't like because you get
familiar with how do you feel about
squid games
i just finished it brian
they're already doing a season two right
love it it's got something to say it's
got something to say gotta have a season
two now how many halloween outfits are
we gonna see in those oh my god
tons
i thought i saw something how much it
was worth
900 900 million to netflix is worth 900
million yeah that's how much it made
yeah what is it what does that mean oh
it means it costs them like i think what
they say 40 million to produce and then
the return on it's 900 million almost a
bill
so they're good you're gonna get
squiddy games part seven it's gonna be
like [ __ ] fast and furious it's that
good
i can't wait till you watch it
i told you it's in the queue
in two years two years we'll talk about
it
i'll be
no it's not six when did it come out
yeah but a year ago but you know like
you know uh it's it's just interesting
to find out all this stuff yeah
especially in half british the royal
family to me so fascinating
2016. they came out 2016. holy [ __ ]
it's fantastic so
what's crazy
is uh the prime minister uh originally
with queen elizabeth he he so
the original king his daughters queen
elizabeth who took over the original uh
king wasn't the original his brother was
and he left that's how the brother got
in then queen elizabeth right she
becomes queen but the original guy quit
he's like i don't like this because they
wouldn't allow him to marry his uh girl
who's from uh new york but she was
divorced so if you're divorced you can't
be in the royal family they don't
tolerate at all because religion right
you're catholic is [ __ ] christians
[ __ ] so you can't do it if you're
divorced yeah they're christians
yeah they're christian so um so he quit
based off the girl but then queen so he
wants to come back years later he's like
hey i feel like i can help out you know
i made some mistakes and help out and
queen elizabeth was gonna hire him and
then these papers which actually didn't
get released to the public to like the
90s which is insane to me because the
royal family suppressed all of it came
out that that that [ __ ] prime
minister had ties to hitler in the nazis
and he sympathized with him and he would
go to there's so many pictures and
documents of him with hitler yeah well
so his plan was
his plan was to help hitler out hillary
clinton so they banned him for life
hitler was always reaching out to the
british empire he had enormous respect
for the british empire and actually
wanted to create an alliance between
japan yeah he considers the aryans of
the east which is in japan yeah japan
the british empire and and and germany
he thought the united states there were
it wasn't going to work out yeah he
never really reached out to them and the
brits were like go [ __ ] yourself with
the exception except for that guy so
then those classified papers got out and
they they suppress they don't want to
get out because make the royal family
terrible so then that came out and she's
like oh you're banned for life dude so
he never was allowed back in wow it's
fascinating though oh yeah but they're
but what's dope is at the end of each
episode like with that stuff they show
the actual pictures and uh documents
pretty cool
it's
fascinating influence that small island
is it not great
so to me i can understand
again i probably learned about it in
high school which i didn't give a [ __ ]
about but it's crazy to me that that
small island because they were
surrounded by water they had to adapt
and well they were they were the reason
they took over
navy's number one the navy is what
allowed them to build their empire
banking system banking and then their
trade so with india with the trade is
what allowed them to take over with all
the money and get resources to expand
even also technology you know europe has
been a war for so long with france with
each other yeah and and so they they
developed there were two things that
gave the europeans such an advantage in
the new world one was weaponry gun
powder cannons
steel but they had all their money to
build all this yeah yeah because of
their trade and their navy and the way
they were
organized the way they organized but
also diseases also they had pathogens
that people just couldn't [ __ ] handle
man you go in there influenza and
diphtheria are you proud to be english
what's happening
english and he's proud to be english
well the brits the brits are taking
untold influence
artistically scientifically
i mean yeah that little island
incredible you almost stay controlled
incredible the world dude they just
released hong kong like two weeks ago
yeah actually 1997
they were just like yeah you can have it
china went we'll take it from you it's
important to know that yeah that's
fantastic you know yeah
what did you get watch the crowning fox
here we go so a man in dallas every
halloween he will go and decorate his
home and every single year without fail
his neighbors call the police because
his decorations are gruesome this year
he decided to amp it up even more
and make it texas chainsaw massachusetts
and he had so many calls from the police
station saying hey we know you do this
every year
we got we got to have you like
just not be as gory and he's like nope
yeah no hold your ground
non-story guys snooze non-storage
[ __ ] areas [ __ ] i mean
it is weird halloween at least i like
the halloween stuff but it's a little
weird
that uh people think oh wow okay that's
it
for kid so my issue with that is that
would scare the [ __ ] kid yeah you
know what like yeah that's the nightmare
before christmas so they're skeletons or
like ghosts that's fun
this is pretty gory dude i mean it's
pretty good this guy went all the way in
there's the blood's spurting
yes
it's hilarious that can't be cheap
no yeah you know what you know what else
is interesting is like when the people
oh look at this you know for halloween
when they go like a million bulbs take
it easy dude what are you trying to do
yeah exactly i got one [ __ ] rack of
lights be cool don't make this [ __ ] oh
it's got a venmo
that's chainsaw all right well
only 580 likes
there you go
that's a little much you for you're
that's very weird holy [ __ ] yeah yeah
listen he does it once a year he goes on
once a year a year let him have his
shine for once again it's just tough if
there's little kids in the neighborhood
they're probably our kids but also click
on him chin with the beetle juice tuxedo
kids kind of like it though if you if
you help them navigate always on the
news here no my kid would be terrible
oops
yeah my son at 10 he'd be like oh
are disturbing
it's been a work in progress over the
years this guy's a little bit here it
gets a little different
say this grisly halloween display
strikes fear
it is very beetle juicy i take full
responsibility
i take full responsibility display these
bowling shoes
can your blood fountains
just go nuts you can't overdo it glory
yard
it's joyous it brings a lot of joy my
way and it really really makes me happy
this guy's single for many of his
neighbors love his elaborate dedication
to all things savage i'm making it up as
i go but not all his neighbors have
agreed his violent display sparks joy
well they're matching a couple of years
ago we had a crazy neighbor over there
well i don't know if she's crazy but
that gruesome
he's like yeah this crazy [ __ ] all
right
yeah it's just too much
it's too much
one year
what else you got um
is this it no that's the same one okay
let's see it'd be fun to see though
where's this at dallas texas oh okay
cool i don't know it won't be up by the
time we're there
no november hopefully it's not up in
november whoa facebook is planning
rebrand to the company with a new name
huh yeah oh wow because they're planning
to do something called
the metaverse
it's like a virtual augmented reality
kind of thing he's so he's your dude huh
yeah he's focusing on that and plus you
know facebook the name already has a lot
of you know baggage with it right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah i think it's pretty
crazy because they create [ __ ] that's a
dick yes
well yeah like
children yeah he's a weird look at him
he's just a weirdo he's like an alien
yeah
very very uh he's a bad guy in a venom
movie you know what i'm saying he's a
weird looking dude did i say multiverse
or midiverse metaverse okay
yeah i don't know what's gonna happen
with them yeah i guess that you know
but also facebook granted about facebook
um it's still the biggest platform in
the world you know that we i don't know
so crazy i know before for you my demo
we don't even [ __ ] like
i can't remember last time we've posted
like someone posted it for me but
i don't know my login yeah
any of you guys on facebook
uh i used to be only four fighter and
the kid in king the stage people like
people like do it for family where would
you advertise there's no advertising
uh i don't do any i don't pay for any
advertising uh
i think for you for your demo older uh
for you again
older for your demo uh facebook should
be good though but i don't do it we
don't do it yeah
facebook's tough oh it's about facebook
physics exit from expense yeah oh no so
that's the last one he's doing i think
it's a sixth one
there's six of them but probably even
more i've only seen one oh never mind on
this
instead of expendable four expendables
four
so that'll be his last one character die
um i don't know if he dies but he's
moving on and then he's going to give
the he says he's passing the baton to
jason statham to take over that
franchise oh jason i'll take it from
here did you say action movie i'll take
it from here
yeah sylvester's [ __ ] great the best
the best what what is that uh ticket
selling out fast rocky what is that he
did like a live 14 million followers
let's see it's what is the tickets are
selling out fast number 11th premiere in
philadelphia
wow oh director's cut of the movie oh
including live q a with sylvester
that'd be fun
wow
look at the size of [ __ ] dolph
what else does he post remember we post
that terrible video with the uh
alligator
allegheny remember that we played it on
here
you know he's got his daughters do a
podcast yeah yeah out of my old studio
they they took over the phone kid set
you know that oh sure yeah really yeah
they're great
yeah they're great cows
all of them all three it's two of the
two of the daughters no he's great man
yeah he's a great guy
great and they are smoke yeah
and they're all great girls like just
silly geese
they are silly people man
yeah
what else you got jen not spoiled
hollywood cows they're just cool girls
oh
i like silly shoes
everywhere yes he is good for him all
right i don't know how much this impacts
you guys but um found out that oh no not
this one well this one's also a trip too
so the senator from uh new york
because of joe rogan and i guess some
other artists that there's a sort of
loophole find a loophole yeah there's a
loophole if you don't want to get into
new york if you're a resident there you
have to be you know vaccinated but if
you're coming in from another place you
don't so it's a loophole there and now
the senator is trying to make sure that
the ufc fighters because of course
they have a year-round man it's going to
be huge yeah michael chandler yeah
olivia and now they're going to have to
get back today
yeah oh so new oh so new york's making
everybody even outsiders
what's up sir i hate when they do this
if grant spencer is out out of town
anti-vaxxer he's not an anti-vaxxer just
he just has [ __ ] he got covered and
he's got better immunity than [ __ ]
he's not an anti-vaxxer yeah it's a
better immunity than if you have the the
check this out
if passed in time the new build could
also prevent several ufcs from be able
to compete at uc 268 november 6.
michael chandler said he's not going to
get it yeah against gaichi he's like i
don't want to do it [ __ ] dude
if if i'm the ufc why even [ __ ] new york
i know but it's such a huge venue it's a
beautiful opportunity i love new york
i'll be there soon listen
but if i'm the ufc you're going to sell
it wherever you go why yeah why play
with this political [ __ ] just do it in
vegas where you know they're not going
to do this to your fighters because now
if chandler can't get it back he's
[ __ ] dude i know that's a such a good
fight too
well well here's the problem what are we
in october yeah mid-october so even if
you were to get vaccinated now with the
protocol two shots he couldn't fight
why when is he supposed to fight
november 6.
so there's no way
you can't get two shots that close
together
a week only a week
no uh two weeks two weeks oh he could do
it then yeah
two weeks it's dicey though with the ufc
i don't know why you can [ __ ] with it
they actually didn't they probably
didn't know they didn't plan for this no
of course not because i know dana
threatened was like okay we just won't
come like all right we'll take it easy
we'll figure it out so we'll see what
happens with this as well just like the
southwest thing yeah airline yeah if you
have coveted you should have an
exemption if you have it yeah and we're
still learning about all that stuff too
yeah okay so like i said this probably
doesn't affect most of us but a lot of
people
will rejoice with this so usually when
you buy a fishing license it's calendar
year
so literally no i'm telling you i'm sure
there's a lot of fishermen that watch
the show okay
in fishing news so yeah so if you buy a
break like right now
i'm trying to fly south without a
[ __ ]
you're going to take your boys fishing
one day right this is good news all
right so sure so usually when you buy a
license like right now if you bought it
in october yeah it's going to last until
december the end of december and you pay
the same price it's ridiculous now
the only thing he's done good but still
it's amazing news
was like you know what this is cool
people all the [ __ ] news like you know
let's give him fish oh yeah i'm going to
bend on fish you know 365 days for that
life
thank god chin that's good news for you
man
thanks man that's hilarious now do you
have to now he's like now i do that but
you have to fish with a mask on i know
it sucks you'll be outdoor we gotta fish
with the mascot this is great when you
pull the fish out of water the fish is a
mascot is this a real yeah this one's a
little older a girl went on tick tock
and made a video wanting to get this to
darius rucker asking if he remembered
her mom because there are a bunch of
photos of her mother and darius rucker
when he was in hootie and the blowfish i
guess they used to date she wants to
know if he still remembers her yeah and
this is the tick tock 26 years
oh wow
[Music]
cool
hoodie's like all right dude be careful
yeah now be cool yeah [ __ ] fighting
why you bringing up oh [ __ ]
i mean
yeah like all right it's a weird thing
that i mean now she's doing it for the
views but jesus christ is going okay so
yeah i saw this i thought it was weird i
guess it's some sort of like illusion
but you tell me if you guys see it
because i don't see it
let me refresh
one second two seconds it's like a new
thing on tick tock well that she did it
it went viral apparently
all right so i can't put the volume
there but look
does it look like her waist disappears
yeah no it's the dress yeah mine's on
the dress so when the dress folds in it
looks like she has a tiny waist so from
there i of course i googled her good
work jay yeah and then she is
ridiculous
yeah
um turns out she has a tiny waist oh
i'll show you some pictures here yeah
let's go ahead and take that in yeah
yeah yeah sure that dress definitely
works yeah um
yeah just hold on
let me find some good ones here look at
this
product
you get the worst pictures dude hey hey
where's this right there god damn it you
like this
no i like the
the other one yeah you're doing all
right gentlemen yeah
well yep she's doing well in life yeah
does she have an only fans or no she's
she's like a friend she's a doctor
she is a lawyer and a lawyer yeah
right yeah she's doing yeah yeah
business is a boom all her own money
yeah so yeah she's just
did you know we're get that cafe we're
going to open up or yeah
jesus christy does she want to do my
social media she doesn't have to know
anything about it yeah i know
all right so the last thing uh
a lot of people are tagging us now
because they see brian everywhere
and this is from russia somewhere in
russia
oh my
[Laughter]
did you post that last one yeah yeah i
post that one the squid game one was
pretty funny too
that's pretty much it guys yeah
boy that is spot-on
and he's happy he's so happy he's not
firing that gun he has those weird mitts
on yep you gotta post that chippy
hi kids this friday friday morning the
flannel thick boy flannels drop and this
red and black you see here and also
green and black
chapelle thick lacy was also with me uh
for the photo shoot so you guys see that
and i was terrified
oh cause we went to a legal yard yeah
he was all nervous because we're in a
yard weren't supposed to be in but it
was pretty fun
but uh
the built stuff sold out but this is the
yep flannels dropped this friday
and then uh november 11th to 13th dallas
addison improv is november 11th through
the 13th and then before that november
4th and 5th i'll be doing pop-up spots
in la stay tuned on my social media for
those dates and times and locations
well we already know where i'm going to
be give him give us this where he gonna
be
uh liberty township this this friday
saturday naples off the hook november 11
12 13 14. by the way
daddy's doing some flying yeah bray
improv brand problem number four and
five sweet then we got five commanding
november six
that's right come come come get some
um october 28 through the 30th
washington dc the dc comedy loft
november 17th one night at tacoma comedy
club and then following day november
18th one night at spokane comedy club
and then a one-nighter at dc or sorry
san jose improv december 1st
that's it kids go get your flannels on
friday i think boy flannels drop go
watch theo vaughn's new special on
netflix available right now go watch it
kids love you guys we're out